Dave Robertson The Los Angeles Dodgers
it has been 21 Seasons since we've had a
repeat World Series champion the Dodgers
have a chance to do that this year but
they're going to have to win three
elimination games in this series alone
they won an elimination game in game
five and that makes it seven in a row
for the Dodgers meanwhile the Braves
trying to punch a ticket to the World
Series for the first time since
1999. Ian Anderson and he's had a great
year he's been excellent in the
postseason but you could say he's
looking for a bounce back here tonight
he is he only made three Innings until
he was pulled out by Brian Snicker the
most important thing for Anderson he's
somehow got to find a way to get through
the first inning era in the first inning
is 6.58 in his only start a two-run home
run given up to Seeger now the offering
from Ian got him he Strikes Out Trey
Turner and a good changeup it's Walker
Bueller's turn coming back for the
second time in this postseason run on
three days rest yeah his first start in
San Francisco four and a third only gave
up a run but coming off a start where he
struggled against the Braves three and
two thirds six Innings four runs only
two earned because of the misplay by
Gavin Lux in center field
[Applause]
from the left field a base hit
a hitting machine right now Eddie
Rosario
thank you
Hobbies deep into Right Center way back
there off the wall
in the second base with a belly flop
Ozzie obis it's a two out double
and the Braves have two hits first three
batters up against Walker Bueller and a
runner at second base two outs here is
Austin Riley and a swing and a drive
down the left field line this is going
to be down what hops out
automatic doubles scores always and the
Braves strike first in the first inning
well because he was able to lay off the
2-2 pitch that you talked about Ronnie
he gets one more on the plate and he
gets it off the end of the bat but
enough to get it to left field 75 hits
with two strikes during the season the
most in Major League Baseball team
curveballs in this at-bat against Smith
for Anderson and Smith shoots one into
right field to base hit Turner's gonna
stop at second
Peterson lobs one into third base
so a walk and a single and now the
Dodgers with their biggest threat count
one away and a swinging out a Miss
Anderson with a strikeout
fourth K he's dialed in today lasted
three innings in game two different
pitcher tonight here's Cody Bellinger
with two on and two outs the 1-2
bouncing ball that is going to go
through a base hit and at home he is
Turner he will score Cody Bellinger ties
the game
slaps one to the opposite field with the
shift on and the Dodgers have squared it
up here in the fourth inning one ball
one strike Pollock doubled his last time
up
here good pitch a fastball got him in
the air and that will retire the side
but the Dodgers score and Cody
Bellinger's postseason run continues
hearing adrianza oh and he swings he
breaks his back that is down the right
field line it is fair and into the car
it goes darno going as fast as he can
but he's held up the catcher was running
and Rod Washington puts up the stop sign
second and third for Atlanta with two
away in the inning so Bessie is starting
to get loose in the Dodger pin Rosario
three for six with runners in scoring
position this postseason
well he has been the man for the Braves
1-2 pitch on the way
driven to right field out there towards
the corner that is a
all right
a three-run homer by Eddie Rosario he
just electrified this crowd and the
Braves have a 4-1 lead
the whole dugouts out to greet him the
whole dugouts out to greet him who is
Eddie Rosario and where the hell did he
come from
Curtain Call
an electrifying moment at truest Park
the postseason Star is Born and his name
is Eddie Rosario AJ events are back out
there to start his second inning of work
hey called strike three
Mentor buries it right at the bottom of
the strike zone 96 mile an hour gas and
it is out number one here in the sixth
inning what a way here is Trey Turner
first ball swinging O'Reilly a little
weird bounce there makes the play no dug
out by Freeman a hole some Gold Glove
skill by the Braves first baseman
two outs in the inning that looked
doomed for disaster from the start oh
yeah did you see the Hop took Riley all
the way over and then Freddie Freeman
the gold Glover what a scoop and I'll
tell you what if the Braves are able to
hang on and win this series this infield
defense is going to be a big reason why
I'm with you almost lost the handle
that's why the Aaron throw but picked by
the goal Club he appreciates it saves a
lot of Errors does Freddie Freeman
let's go
three up three down two k's he wants
them both now he's forced to face off
yeah three batters is the minimum you
have to face
runners go and a ball ball four albies
draws the walk three consecutive walks
the bases are loaded and Dave Roberts is
on his way out
and now he's up with the bases loaded
with the Braves leading 4-1 in the sixth
well Dave Roberts going to kind of
knowing this I got to keep it right here
this is the game
here's a 1-2 and a call strike three 99
mile an hour fastball Trident gets out
of it the brave strand the base is
loaded that could be big
and so Mentor two scoreless and now Ron
it'll be luke Jackson out of the Atlanta
pin one ball one strike to count on
Taylor gets one high and deep to left
way back and it is off the top of the
wall Taylor on his way to second base
he's in with a double he scalded that
ball to left field he almost hit one out
and Luke Jackson gives up a lead off
double here in the seventh inning
and down the left field line that is a
fair ball coming in to score is Taylor
Bellinger will stop at third a two
strike double for AJ Pollock and it's
four to two and the Dodgers have two in
scoring position with nobody out in the
seventh now Tyler Matic enters this game
Runners at second and third nobody out
of the seventh anything medium deep to
the Outfield will be plenty to score
Bellinger who runs well
Pollock very fast as well at second base
here's a 1-2 and a swing he had a miss
that was a big strikeout for Matson one
away
one out one and two a call strike three
matzik
Burns off the edge struck him out pitch
on the way got him swinging strike three
unbelievable
magic all sorts of fired up as he walks
off the field
he limits the damage to just the one run
three huge strikeouts the Atlanta Braves
have won four consecutive home games in
the postseason they tighten their D
Guillermo Heredia will play center that
moves Duvall with a strong arm and right
and on the mound
closer Will Smith
got him
What a Way full count one out here he
comes a swing and a mess he struck him
out two gone in the inning
one ball and no strikes
pigeon away there's a shot to Dansby he
slides to it he's got it throws over
there is a new champion of the national
league and it is the Indiana Brave
they have won the 2021 National League
pennant and the Atlanta Braves are going
to the World Series
they are celebrating on the field they
have dethroned the 106 win Dodgers and
for the first time since 1999 the
Atlanta Braves are going to the fall
classic Michelob Ultra organic Seltzer
as real as it tastes